we're here at simpang asia to try some
authentic indonesian cuisine i'm
bringing my co-worker keith who's never
had indonesian food before and hopefully
he'll love it we got our inspiration a
lot from uh street food and tradition
i'm gonna just order a bunch of stuff
and i was wondering if you could help
guide me through okay what it is because
i don't know what i'm doing nasi goreng
it's a fried rice indonesian special
fried rice
wow that is just excellent fried rice it
says some sweetness some smokiness a
nice amount of salt to it the chicken is
so good i think it's the chicken that
has a little seasoning on it itself that
is giving me that vinegar or acid i
think it might be that sweet soy sauce
is it a sweet soy sauce is that what
they said they put on it
i only eat this and be super happy it's
really good
[Music]
it kind of reminds me of what butter
beer would taste like
caramely and bitter so it's a little
more burnt
sweetness to it and also look at how
many worms are in my straw these green
bits don't really have that much flavor
but they're fun as they like shoot into
my mouth
so this he said it was a salad that's
blanched this has so many different
textures it's fun to play i know it's
crazy you've got
there's some tofu in here so once a
prawn cracker and one's uh something
else cracker yeah we listened real well
[Music]
do they saute satay they do not saute
they grill saute wow they barbecue saute
crazy it's somehow tough and tender at
the same time like it has a good amount
of bite but it's very easy to chew the
meat that's like a nice savory char and
then when you have the sweet peanut
sauce to kind of balance out
these are some chewy noodles they're a
thicker noodle and they've been fried so
they got a lot of texture going on you
can taste there's more sweetness in this
it's a little it's richer heavier this
is a much heavier dish there's very
clearly a chinese influence on this dish
yeah absolutely
there's so much flavor in this fish it's
hard to describe it's very sweet and
barbecuey and the skin is very nicely
crispy i think they said they marinate
it overnight i always worry whenever i
get whole fish because i'm not very good
at finding fish bones until my throat
finds them for me oh you got you got
that meat right off that bone no problem
robin
[Music]
this is like a combo plate you normally
don't get to unwrap your food wow look
at that it's like a little brain so this
is the chicken and then there's an egg
it's like a spicy deep fried boiled egg
oh and there's some beets and there's
some beef all those vegetables are
really good this meat is just like all
the way off that bone it's so tender and
there's a lot of flavor all over the
place
it is super rich this is the dish that
somebody brings to your potluck dinner
then it's gone the meat is completely
coated with bits of spices and coconut
because it's been marinating for so long
deep down there's just flavor in every
part of it the flavor is all the way
through everything cnn did a poll with
like 35 000 people
and they did their favorite dish in the
world yeah number one was befriending
really
in the world number two was nasi goreng
there might be some country bias to
those people i think the top two are
from one nation it is the fourth biggest
country in the world it's the fourth
biggest country in the world i think so
we're about to eat bananas with cheese
and chocolate and condensed milk
[Music]
i didn't expect that texture it's like
kind of crunchy it's a really young
banana i'm sorry it's what it's a young
banana isn't it
what are you talking about a young
banana yeah it's very firm oh you mean
under ripe banana
i knew that banana since it was young
i don't taste the cheese at all i'm
wondering if the cheddar because cheddar
has some salt in it
is meant to put some salt in the dish
and pull away the chocolate and
sweetness a little bit
i think so because the one thing i've
noticed with all the dishes is they all
have an element of sweetness and
saltiness
some of them also have spiciness to it
what i liked about all these dishes is
most of these dishes are based off
street foods so you've got fried rice
you've got you know meat skewers you've
got the the whole fish that they said is
often found near the beach yeah it's all
very rustic it just seems there's a lot
of time and effort put into each of
these dishes i appreciate you bringing
me here i didn't know much about
indonesian food and now i do yeah and uh
now i'm very full and i'd like to take a
nap i think i want the noodles if you if
i can have the noodles and maybe some of
that fish if you're not going to take
olive it home you don't see that yeah
oh yes
[Music]
you